this is like an art masterpiece I mean
the art the art house look look at the
shaky cam zooms that's so wonderful
look it's an upside down lamp so
beautiful
we're alone
life is only on earth melancholy is
directed by lars von trier and a lot of
people aren't exactly big fans of him
he's made some anti-semitic remarks he
was actually kicked out of Kon Film
Festival but most of his movies I looked
at his works of art very controversial
films this film isn't so much as
controversial as some of his past films
are this one stars Kirsten Dunst is
about it's about mmm here we go
Kirsten Dunst plays a very depressed
girl and there is a planet newly
discovered planet named melancholia that
is suddenly on a collision course with
earth and people are wondering will it
pass by or will it collide so we have a
very depressed girl who hates life this
is her she wants to live I have a planet
that is coming towards Earth that could
end her life she's not sure if it's
going to happen or not and it's kind of
a drama about sadness and depression and
acceptance
and not for long
it's a very similar field a Tree of Life
actually where it's kind of euphoric
when you're watching it but it also
makes you feel sad and you're not
exactly sure why I looked up melancholia
and melancholia according to the
dictionary is a depression state of mind
where a person is extremely sad and has
ill-founded fears where their whether
they're just afraid of everything and
they're not exactly sure why it derives
from the word melancholy which is also a
deep sadness or you know state of
depression so this film isn't exactly a
fun movie to watch it's one of those
movies where you admire it for its craft
but it's not the movie that you go to to
have a good time never seen you so happy
I think because the film so accurately
portrays a deep depression someone who's
going through extreme sadness that it
it's it's difficult to watch but I
really admired Kirsten Dunst performance
I thought she was excellent in the film
she won Best Actress at the Conn Film
Festival I've always liked her it's nice
to see her doing something a little more
ambitious this is one of those movies
it's very challenging and it's hard for
me to even to review it I admire it for
its craft similar to Tree of Life
however I didn't find great enjoyment
watching it so if you are a fan of super
arthouse film very artsy then you'll
probably like this more than I did
because I do like art house films I just
I think that sometimes art house films
mask a poorly constructed story with
that guise of boots are this is really
artsy so you will like it because of
that but there's weak story elements
here there's there's a script here that
in a lot of ways is just it has a lot of
plot holes a lot of weird things that
happen that is are never explained I
mean like there's this underlying plot
element that Kirsten Dunst I can tell
the future or something and it's never
gone into never explained never explored
you're just kind of supposed to accept
it
I thought you mean you wanted this but I
do
sorry sir and I think that a lot of
times critics are like they expect that
they have to like a film that is very
arty and ambitious and independent you
know and they don't always express
everything they feel I don't know if
that's true I think it is for some
people but this film is a film that I
can admire because of its the way it's
constructed and the way that it has
definitely ambitious things and some
really good images in the film but I
can't really say that I enjoyed watching
it I am however going to give the film a
B and I'll tell you why I'm gonna give
the film a B I think that it's a
good-looking film despite the fact that
there's overuse of handheld cam I don't
want to say this as a bad movie because
it's not a bad movie it's really
ambitious it's big and it's it's really
well done in a lot of ways and another
thing is it accurately portrays
depression and what people dealing with
depression go through so I can't fault
it for that it's just not an enjoyable
film for me to watch I didn't find a lot
of pleasure in watching a woman deal
with that kind of thing it's gonna be
the most beautiful sight ever
the performances are great and it looks
great so I'm going to get the film beat
it honestly is the exact same feel I had
after I saw Tree of Life a little bit
confused I had to really think about it
if you are a fan of art house cinema I I
am but just not not this much art this
is this is super arty stuff going on if
you like Kirsten Dunst if you like Laura
sponsors other films then I would check
this out if you just want to go to the
theater to try to have a good time maybe
I have some escapism this is not your
movie
so if you liked my review you can
subscribe my channel and get stuck mine
eyes